ciao a tutti benvenuti solite storie sia
serialità vitale e oggi andremo a fare
una cosa che noi abbiamo mai fatto
andiamo a fare lo slime al contrario
però in carenza non andiamo a fare lo
slam proprio con gli ingredienti però
prenderemo degli schleck che abbiamo già
fatto altrimenti troppo noioso vedere
sempre colla schiuma da barba le stesse
cose falcate quindi prenderemo
dell'islam che già abbiamo pronti e
cercheremo di fare delle forme oppure vi
faremo vedere come sono l'inizio poi una
volta mi sbagliati come si trasformano
per verranno semplicemente messi al
contrario ho visti dopo con video che
hanno fatto luca e katie che hanno fatto
varie cose fatte al contrario quindi con
il video messo al contrario della super
divertente e questo trend dello slam
al contrario backwards c'è già da un
paio d'anni su youtube ma noi non lo
abbiamo mai fatto
quindi abbiamo deciso di provare anche
noi più sarà a smr quindi prendete
subito nel qpr perché ci saranno un
sacco di rumore super rilassanti
formento non farò casini a partecipare e
giocare anche voi potrete indovinare che
tipo di slime sarà cioè perché vuoi
vedere che prima lo slime smontato e poi
si rimonta quindi potete indovinare
dall'inizio che tipo di trend sarà altro
di che colore viene ma dell'accesso in
bellezza
volete vedere altri video del genere un
altro slam al contrario o video s m
vedremo se volete vedere vitale mangiare
oppure mettetevi comode andate a letto
sul divano sulla post rock cuffie
iniziamo subito
[Applauso]
[Musica]
allora pensi sapere nei commenti qual è
quello che vi è piaciuto di più
lasciateci il timing stampo di quello
che vi è piaciuto di più e noi andremo
arrivederci li potesse sapere se
vorreste vederne un altro anche per noi
è stato molto rilassante alex pato
volete rivederla quale è stato quello
che ti è piaciuto di più penso picazio
pento ciao che è tipica cifra un calore
certo era un modo di pd vigili contro
bezzati parla almeno di più quello
bronzo colibrì con i brillantini ai
pigmenti perché sotto le mani sembrava
sabbia tipo quando si perché era quello
in cui abbiamo mischiato tutti i
pigmenti tutti i glitter forse sta per
se ve lo ricordate anzi mi lascio magari
la castellina così andate a vederlo
troppo bello davvero di consigliateci
nei commenti altre challenge che volete
che facciamo io non vi lasciamo con
quattro cartellini sacrificare prima dai
nostri altri video clicchiamo su
quell'area versione però il pianeta